from our vehicle to my obligatory well
is unbelievably important because it
helps me forget what I've been through
zahia unha swanee from Syria has been
living in a home for asylum seekers in
Berlin for around five months Alice wani
is an opponent of the Assad regime and
like thousands of others he had to flee
his homeland he risked his life to get
from Turkey to Greece and then made his
way through the Balkans
muffin and fish out there market are
Becky I don't like talking about what
happened on the truth especially on the
boat but it reminds me how close I was
to dine everything could have been over
in a second the months of effort would
have been in vain no more dozen mom I
don't want to think about any of it
anymore difficulties we had in Hungary
running away from the police because we
weren't registered with mango yea vote
Mustafa goon rock is also originally
from Syria he's lived in Berlin for more
than 40 years but he still feels
connected to his homeland in a local
cultural center he takes care of Syrian
refugees he also founded a football team
for them Syrian SB it's far too quickly
she finishes yeah should be at the
images on TV were difficult for me to
take I can follow it's tough to see your
own people fleeing violence and risking
their lives for give a loot of course
standards leave it the foot so I said
these refugees my people need to note
these are flush linger my lair Lance
loitered you because I believe that's
the case top I also said sports are the
only way to give these people something
that will help them forget their
everyday reality yes my advice oogie bo
z year altec is my ferguson
Alice wani now also plays for Syrian sv
while fleeing to Germany he had to make
do without his hobby for six months
full authority my mouth it was like a
suicide of the soul I'm not playing
football for so long Elena I immediately
looked around thank God my cousin was a
member of Syrian is new and took me
along haha swanee now has a game almost
every weekend in goonrock steam gum rock
is proud that Syrian sv have made it to
the district class of the german
football association smartly license in
Emma I voting achievements are a way of
gaining recognition in this society sooo
bad i goota possible if someone's a good
footballer knowing us whether he's
Syrian Egyptian or Palestinian Palace it
is a today Syrian SVR taking on SG
medecine Cleveleys felda the team gets
some final tactical instructions then
it's out on the pitch what the color
vehicle should hire them for me playing
football for this team is as important
as eating and drinking she'll changed
everything for me when I arrived in
Berlin I was alone with no no I'm a year
I have friends we've become a great team
Chevy ones cut from the same cloth going
much more whether we didn't we thought
the Syrian sv starting eleven come from
various regions and social classes but
they all share the experience of being
asylum seekers that together with their
love of football binds them together
the mom loved own daddy suited the other
when we're playing a Syrian sv I feel
like I'm back home where I used to play
on the streets of my neighborhood all
religious and ethnic groups play
together in this club Christian Sunnis
Kurds that's something great for Syria
for Berlin and for the rest of Europe
and as all the other teams in the
district classes are finding out Syrian
SVR no pushovers they've earned their
opponents respect alafaya they're all
fair they're enthusiastic and good
sportsman they're very ambitious we're
just out to have a good time but you
sense their hearts are in it even though
it's just another Saturday match to
prefer some sucks feel it but before the
Syrians could take to the pitch ghum
Hulk had to wage some hard battles with
German Football bureaucracy in order to
get permission to play in the district
class they had to submit proof of their
status as players from Syria
so loosen list and chicken with Nahrmahn
they have to send Liz with names and
birthdays that's dangerous with the
situation in Syria the way it is right
now a [ __ ] Felicia suit on soon then
the geheime do services or anomaly
Krieger if the secret police get hold of
the names and know that someone has fled
to Germany design ominous relatives are
in danger of being arrested or even
killed engi father so after to veltan
kakuta through value al has swanee and
his teammates are part of what's
becoming a syrian german football
subculture and they have a role model to
look up to a player who came to Germany
with his Syrian refugee parents 10 years
ago and is now a star midfielder for
Borussia mönchengladbach
till mom doesn't matta mundo food is a
really great player does I've seen lots
of his games I know mentally I did what
we all want to do what was achieved his
goal all the hardships I've been through
our motivation to keep battling until
I've realized my dream la salud
knee-high and heavenly Bedelia how to be
bossy Syrian SB beats the team of
Germans from clearly spelled of 43 it's
a small victory but one that symbolizes
these men's return to a semblance of
normality